hello everyone in this video I'm going
to talk about the symbolism of hair in
the story of Rapunzel it is an away
continuation of the last video I did
directly on the symbolism of hair in the
Bible but I also wanted to to use a
story that is from another source so
here a fairy tale to talk about the a
coherence of the symbolism of hair
[Music]
this is Jonathan Petro welcome to the
symbolic world
and so most of us will know the story of
Rapunzel
I'll give the details of it just to give
you two to start usually the story is
starts with the idea of a couple who's
pregnant and very poor and a man goes
and steal some cabbages for his wife in
this witch's garden and the witch
catches him and he promises either they
they make us a very disturbing trade
where he promises to give there for his
born in exchange for the cabbage or else
she tells the man that he is she is
going to take their first child when
it's born and so when the child is born
the witch takes a child and then raises
her up in a tower and raises are there
with no with no entrance to the tower
when the young woman becomes a teenager
she has this long you know flowing hair
and the witch when she wants to engage
with the young lady she goes up to the
tower
and says rapunzel rapunzel let down your
hair and then the witch can climb up and
can gauge with the lady so then with
Rapunzel the idea is that the witch will
not let Rapunzel go and often the story
is interpreted in relating to this
notion of an overbearing mother of a
devouring mother that will not let her
daughter grow up and enter into
relationship but she wants to protect
her and so I think that that's a fair
interpretation but what I want to look
at is especially how the symbolism of
hair plays into this story and so of
course she has this just kind of long
unnatural hair and in the story later on
the prince will come and will see the
witch saying rapunzel rapunzel let down
your hair and the prince will climb up
will go up and then when the the the
witch is no longer there he will himself
call up to Rapunzel to the downer hair
climbs up her hair and then they meet
they fall in love
etc etc in the very early versions of
the story after the princes several
visits Rapunzel actually gets pregnant
and they plan on how to get her to
escape her the witch
is grasped and so as they're planning to
help her escape the story usually has it
that Rapunzel will make a mistake when
she's speaking to the witch will let it
not be known that the prince is coming
to seer in the very very early versions
of she says something like that her her
her dress is becoming a little too tight
around the belly suggesting of course
that she's pregnant in other virgins
she makes the mistake of saying as the
witch is climbing up how you know it's
funny that the prince when he climbs up
her hair it doesn't hurt her as much as
the the witch you know and so because of
that the witch then cuts off Rapunzel's
hair usually tosses Rapunzel out you
know out into the the wilderness and
when the prince climbs up the hair this
time he calls rapunzel Rapunzel sees
this hair come down he climbs up but
when he arrives he finds the the witch
who is behind the hair now and she
pushes him off the tower he falls into a
thorn bush and which blinds him and then
he wanders through the wilderness blind
for quite a while until one day he he
hears the voice of Rapunzel in the
forest once again Rapunzel has been
living in the forest and raising his
children basically raising the often
it's twins a boy and a girl and and so
he hears the voice he calls to her
Rapunzel comes and she takes him in his
arm
she cries and the tears her tears will
heal the the prince and there you go now
they're back together again and some
virgins he in touching her hair then her
hair will grow out again and and and
she'll be back to how she was before and
so of course you can know you can
obviously see you know the whole like I
said devoured mother and also you know
allusions to to relationship alluding to
the relationship between the man and the
and the woman but we really need to look
at it in our case look at it's a very
it's a very deep story it has a lot
going for it but we need to look at it
especially in relationship to hair and
so
the way you have to kind of understand
it first of all is we have to understand
this first of all this notion that the
woman who is up in the tower is of
course related to the man and the woman
come together so it is related to the
notion of the couple but you also have
to understand it kind of in the medieval
idea of the of the chivalrous romance
where the woman up in the tower
represents not only let's say the
relationship that he can have with a
woman but represents also we could say
the the the the mysterious spiritual
aspect of the feminine we see of course
this vision of the world in Dante where
it is Beatrice who leads him up you know
the mountain up to the up to the top of
the mountain where she even at some
point is traded and and then it's the
Holy Virgin kind of guides him up
towards God and so in the chivalrous
idea the the dedicating yourself to a
lady could be a manner in which we could
enter into the mystery of of God we can
encounter God through our dedication to
a a woman to a dedication to a lady and
so this woman up in the tower is not
only a woman in this in the strict sense
but it also represents you know this
mystery you could say this almost the
spiritual mystery that this prince can
come to encounter and so the hair as
I've talked about in the symbolism in my
movie my video about the symbolism of
hair the hair represents these externals
the hair in this sense represents this
external thing which reaches from the
woman out into the outside and so when
the Prince comes that's what he sees
first what he sees first of rapunzel is
her hair just like what we see of
anybody when we first encountered them
is this kind of outer showing that they
have in the case of hair it goes very
far because hair is just like we talked
about also in the video about the the
Lord of the Rings and the Ring of Power
hair is you could say the first ornament
it is this first ornament
the closest to us because it actually
comes out of us but it can be it can be
molded it can be change color it can be
quaffed in a way that acts very much as
an ornament and we everybody knows that
everybody knows especially you know
women who will may spend an enormous
amount of time on their hair dyeing
their hair doing all kinds of things in
order to use their hair as a form of
ornamentation like makeup or or wearing
a nice outfit the hair becomes the first
outfit you could call it the first
garment okay
and so in that sense the Prince
encounters this garment encounters this
ornament and uses the ornament and the
ornament becomes a way for him to access
the the princess so in that case the
ornament her hair becomes the glory of
this this princess you know that it's
too far from him that is too removed
from him and by by climbing up the this
external by by using these external
signs of her he is able to come into
contact with her okay
and that of course is true of everything
okay
that is true of let's say religious
structures let's say art the the church
building is a way is an external
manifestation of something which can
help us bring us closer to to God bring
us closer to that mystery you know all
the externals all the liturgies all the
all the everything that you know even
the Bible itself all these externals are
there to act as a kind of ladder to
bring us closer to the mystery to
something which is beyond the external
something which is hidden in that secret
place and so here it is the prince who
goes up and and encounters the princess
so now when you know the the let's say
the problem happens the which cuts off
her hair and then the witch uses their
hair but now the which is using the hair
in the negative aspect of ornamentation
in the negative aspect of externals
she's using
this beautiful you know long hair to
hide herself to hide the fact that she's
actually an ugly horrible witch and so
the prince sees the hair and he is in
this case now he is actually duped by
the hair these external are are are
actually leading him into air because
he's trusting only the externals and has
doesn't isn't looking further than the
ornamentation and so that is true once
again about anything that is external
you know and that's why we have always
have this conflict within religion
within christianity to say you know how
important are these external things you
know are they idols are they are they do
they actually lead us astray rather than
lead us towards God and the truth is
that they they're both they both they
can lead these both lead you to because
without them you would not be have
access to to to to the mystery but if
you trust only on the external and you
don't use them as a way to get closer to
that mystery then those externals can
leave you astray and and and so in this
case the the prince trusts the hair you
know and then when he climbs the hair he
finds that the hair was actually hiding
this horrible witch so what does it
caused this his his mistake his error in
entrusting only the externals makes him
fall and falls into a thorn bush now for
anybody who knows anything about
biblical symbolism you will see that
this relationship between the hair and
the thorn bush is extremely important
because of course the thorn bush is that
first sign in the bible of the fall and
so when you when when when Adam and Eve
fall God says that the that the world
will now produce thorns and in order to
protect yourself from those thorns God
gives them these garments of skin which
are represented of course by these hairy
garments and so you have the hair to
protect you from the thorns now the
prince
is led astray by the hair he's he's been
tricked by externals and because of that
then he he loses his his he loses the
protection of of the externals and smack
he hits in he goes into the thorn and he
becomes blind of course the blindness is
exactly that exactly what he already had
gone through he was already a form of
blindness which led him to trust only
the hair Rapunzel's hair instead of
instead of being attentive to what the
hair is connected to which had caught
him to fall in the first place so he
falls he becomes blind that's of course
a a perfect image of this this
forgetfulness or our this incapacity to
actually see things for what they are
and and is a consequence of the trick in
which he's and let himself fall that
he's also that he didn't have the
strength to see beyond the hair let's
say and so the the prince then wanders
of course we are wandering in the
wilderness just like you know just like
the Israelites wandered in the
wilderness when they they didn't trust
God just like Cain wandered in the
wilderness when he slew his brother this
notion of wandering in the wilderness is
really this idea being lost having lost
meaning having lost the capacity to see
the world for what it is and to be led
astray to be he could have been on water
he could have been you know basically it
is this loss of a capacity to see
capacity to see meaning is being lost in
the wilderness for those who have more
questions about that I would say read
mature pathos book my brother's book the
language of creation in that book he
talks about wilderness as well as this
falling away from meaning and this
incapacity to see to see the meaning in
the world so the Prince wanders off and
then finally he hears the voice and
hearing the voice of Rapunzel is once
again then being reconnected to his
first goal being reconnected to the
meaning which he had lost which
he had which he had not been able to see
beyond the externals and now he hears
the voice and of course hearing the
voice is in in in in in symbolism it
really is this kind of inner
relationship to hear someone's voice is
to encounter that person in a very
intimate way in the Old Testament for
example we don't see God but we hear God
and this hearing is really this intimate
relationship the world is created by
word it is that link to word and so by
hearing the princess he recognizes her
he's not seduced by her outer beauty
anymore he can't even access it but he
then finds her again through herself
through her her more her deeper self you
could say by hearing her voice and
connecting to her voice and then of
course the the the the the the princess
in her feminine guys you could say she
washes away his disease she washes away
his his incapacity to see and there you
go the Prince recovers his sight
recovers his goal and recovers of course
the princess and not only that but he
also discovers the fruit of his purpose
of his gold in the two children the twin
children which represent having a boy
and a girl twins will also represent
this kind of you could say totality of
his union with Rapunzel and so you have
this new wholeness which is created by
the by this reconnecting with Rapunzel
at the end and so we can see now once we
see it how hair functions perfectly in
that story function perfect functions
perfectly in the way that it is really
is this double bind where there is this
external thing that is there to act as a
kind of ladder in order to bring you
closer to the mystery but if you only
trust the ladder and you're not you're
not trying to see what's beyond it then
it can become a form of hiding and a for
of artifice that that can get you lost
that can that can make you loss and it
can make you lose sight and lose the
deeper meaning and so I think that's
really important especially for this
whole discussion in in Christianity that
we've had these extremes in Christianity
where in certain branches of
Christianity people have fought so much
the external forms and in other you know
in other times in other places people
have relied so much on outer forms but
it really is only those two things
coming together the outer and the inner
the the external manifesting the
internal and the the internal being the
final goal it's a the the final purpose
of what all those external czar for
that's how the world can exist and it's
really the only way that the world can
exist properly and so I hope that you
enjoyed this video about hair um this
week I'm going to answer a lot of people
in my last video been asking questions
about all the art that I have put up in
my in my office and so this week I think
it's this week or next week I'm going to
do the the QA live and in the QA I'm
going to describe a little bit of the
art why I have it up you know some
people ask what is God's dog other
people ask what is this man sitting on a
lion and so I well I will deal with all
that in the QA the QA is available live
and the questions are available for
supporters but I think this month I will
put out the QA once it's finished I will
put it out publicly so that everybody
can get that information if that's
something that you're interested in and
so everybody again once again thanks for
sharing all this you know thanks for
being part of this discussion and I'll
see you soon